there breaking tonight president biden
is promoting what appears to be the
latest plank in a massive
tax and spend platform a 2.3 trillion
dollar
infrastructure plan the president
unveiled the broad strokes of the
proposal a short time ago at an event in
pittsburgh
calling it a once in a generation
investment
the plan comes on the heels of a two
trillion dollar coronavirus relief
package
and speculation on just how president
biden plans to pay
for all of it white house correspondent
peter ducey starts us off tonight
live from pittsburgh good evening peter
good evening brett the president is
referring to this plan as being as
ambitious and transformational as the
interstate highway system
or the space race and it comes with a
higher price tag than any government
spending proposal
ever plus the biggest tax hike
in decades it's not a plan that tinkers
around the edges
it's a once in a generation investment
in america
the headlines of the infrastructure
section of the biden infrastructure plan
115 billion dollars to modernize roads
and bridges
most in need of repair 111 billion to
replace all
lead pipes and 213 billion to build or
retrofit
2 million affordable sustainable houses
it's about infrastructure
to pay for it the white house wants to
raise the corporate tax rate 228 percent
from 21 and
raise the global minimum tax to 21
percent from 13.
this has been an administration of the
government by the government for the
government
the only thing it appears they're in
favor of is more government spending
more taxes
and more government power over your
lives the chamber of commerce argues
against
new taxes with this properly done a
major investment in infrastructure today
is an investment in the future and
like a new home should be paid for over
time say 30 years
by the users who benefit from the
investment i am concerned
about the level of our national debt
we've reached a critical point here
but this infrastructure bill is more of
a spending bill because
it's not just about infrastructure the
american jobs plan will lead
to a transformational progress in our
efforts to tackle climate change
the white house wants 174 billion
dollars to
win the electric vehicle market 16
billion dollars to plug oil wells and
clean abandoned mines and 10 billion
dollars
to create a civilian climate corps the
president is also calling for
100 billion dollars for racial and
gender equity in the job market
addressing infrastructure climate and
environmental justice together
and creating millions of good paying
jobs is just the right combination
these proposals are alarming to leaders
in fossil fuel producing states like
north dakota
the united states finally got ourselves
in a position where we geopolitically
where we could
sell energy to our friends and allies
versus buy it from our enemies
and now with this administration we
appear to be reversing course on that
but the president is trying to live up
to his campaign promise to be the most
progressive ever it's big yes
it's bold yes and we can get it done
and there's actually two parts this was
just
the american jobs plan the president
says in the next few weeks he will
unveil
the american family plan which is
expected to be loaded with social
programs but is guaranteed to cost
more taxpayer money because it does not
count towards today's multi-trillion
dollar
price tag or tax hikes right
you know peter today the president said
he wants to reach out to republicans he
wants to have republicans in the oval
office
but it was not clear whether he had
talked
to the senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell do we know
and i'm just looking at my phone to
because i've been
trying to get clarity from the white
house but the president said today that
he has spoken to mitch mcconnell about
this plan it's just not clear
whether or not that was during the
transition when we know they talked or
after swearing in
when our last update was that they had
not had any kind of a meaningful
conversation post-inauguration
right okay peter thank you come